how that had a bit bit burry bill
delivered a little but I do they were
probably dude have dinner to do look if
you did it you little turtle turtle
looked up to to duty to do do dodo do
dodo do do do do do do do do do Lewton
to give dudududududududu and if the
total total download owner ooh look at
the director director retire huh can
anybody see me can't everybody hear me
can anybody hear me
can anybody see me
hi hi hi hi
hi
hi hi hi hi hello hello hello hello
hello hello hi hi hi hi hi hi hi hi hi
hi hi hi and we are all setting up just
got to get set up for what we got going
on yeah probably slow mode would be a
good idea at this point in time there
are going to be a lot of people here if
n if last week is anything to go by yes
and my headphones are dying and or dead
so I'm stuck with just your butts today
it's sad but hey I'll make do with what
I got it dip dip hello hello everybody
hello hello hello my day is just fine I
had a wonderful day by that I mean I had
a wonderful night last night I drank a
lot of LA a lot of beer I drank a la lot
of beer
I dry la la laaaa beer I drank about two
and a half liters of beer I think that's
about right yeah that's about right mmm
I did not catch the walking dead
marathon I didn't need to see him again
and I don't have cable what happened to
my headphones hell if I know
they just started crackling up so I'm
gonna need to get some new ones so in
the meantime just earbuds it's all I got
and I can plug them directly into my
microphone how weird is that so anyway
it is one minute to go time we are going
to start any minute now is everybody
ready for some amnesia custom stories
yeah yeah I think so no okay all right
all right no child of ragnarok said we
weren't ready
I guess we're not ready so I'm just
gonna
slowmode means everyone can still type
but each individual person has to wait
so
uh-huh
I see where's my chair I'm pretty sure
I'm sitting on it cuz that's what chairs
are meant for anyway it's time list
there dude your dude is are we all good
on Twitch can you guys hear me in the
game okay I just want to make sure that
you guys can hear my voice and the game
are coming in loud and clear no
crackling no anything like that good all
good on your end I'll get on my end all
good on everybody's end okay good and I
do have a new graphics card from last
week I have a GTX 670 now as opposed to
my old Radeon 5850 so it's quite an
upgrade so I and my headphones died I'm
resorting to ear buds cranking up the
tunes up in here here we go
we ready ready to go here we go pink we
are playing the cruel ways of dr.
Richard Jones another highly reviewed
highly rated and he's accustomed story
it's just a loading screen right now say
you don't need to worry about it
I feel ready for any action to start
ooh hello okay pretty typical start of
the game
now come on Barry oh thank you
nothing in there no Dede clunk clink ah
uh-oh are they intending to hurt me
early on oh um you don't know me but I
know exactly everything about you I
observed you for a long time and I think
you are a great test subject you only
have to do one thing find a way out and
survive mm-hmm it pretty much always
starts out in a room and there's blood
everywhere always a good sign
Oh No is that now what's happening I'm
not allowed to go out that door no aah
that's I I can't do that
all right fine fine gotta be a key
around here somewhere right
hmm well don't tell me I'm gonna get
stuck right in the beginning oh of
course
duh one idiot noop noop get out of here
shut up
nobody ever nobody ever shut up
it was obvious and I got plenty of oil
all right
they got me a pretty good amount of
stuff set off right in the beginning and
that looks diabolical and evil I'm
looking forward to that all right
ah no no and that well yes I like it
all right so that was yes
please remove all right these rooms are
awfully tiny it's kind of cramped like
moving on straight from one to the other
is a long thank you
see I guess you have a problem with the
second door right well just expect the
floor thoroughly and you will find the
key well I didn't really have any
trouble but thanks for the advice
give me pardon me yeah boy inspect the
floor all righty then
all righty then yes is many chairs and
smashing stuff up inspect the floor say
wha
Oh what's that no that's a plate pile up
chair pile up get out of here come on
you stupid chairs get out of here yeah
damn alright so well
alright well inspect the floor do you
think I'm blocking my own way I think
your block don't tell me what I'm
blocking I know what I'm blocking hmm
well the floor looks pretty even just
smashing up your [ __ ]
dr. Jones how do you like me now dr.
Jones this is the cruel ways of dr.
Richard Jones the key is so obscure on
this one
hmm is it so well ain't that just a pain
in the butt ah friggin chair pilot man
there's so many of these things
the owner is hard to get there forget
everywhere get out of here hey good girl
son of a mother I'm gonna all stab you
Oh shudders but the entirety of
the bookcase maybe and who said it was
on the floor
inspect the floor that is right
inspect the floor well I'm not seeing it
inspect the floor hmm
no one is that my door oh not in this
room the other room oh oh oh oh you oh
well that would have been totally
obvious was this come on come on come on
come on come on there we go that would
have been ha ha ha
okay all right
well it's fun I mean that that was not
obscure at all I was just looking in the
wrong room
yeah I'm a super genius I'm a super
genius
yeah I'm pretty smart about everything
yeah I'm the best I'm the best there
ever was actually one thing I got I'm
gonna change something it's a bit
actually I cranked up the brightness
just cuz I thought it was gonna be too
bright but actually I want to make it a
bit more atmospheric it's just nicer
what it is hi
here we go try to light your ways
don't waste your oil try not to die
dr. Jones okay alright then try to light
your way I'm getting the idea that dr.
Jones is a bit of a son of a [ __ ] and I
don't like him crowbar mmm old rusty
crowbar well look at this
how lovely Kurt Jahnke
possibly know was that say I need to use
that on a door cuz I lost its key what
if I never had the key oh this looks fun
what if we got here [ __ ] yeah come on
huh alright then another one
how many jump scares are gonna be in
this game cause the jump scare that jump
scare no
then Ozzy jump-scare no bed jump-scare
no alright then alright oh oh man you
know when I was playing amnesia custom
stories previously I hadn't gotten the
opportunity to really encounter the kind
of custom of stories that are just like
all jump scares all the time so I'm
hoping that this isn't one of those
click link cannot use this item this way
cannot use this item this way so what's
the point of this okay I got the key so
I can obviously go around here
what is that glowing blue what is that
I'm not sure I have no idea yes there is
no peel box set up just yet I'm working
on it
I'll get it soon so that you guys can
send me stuff oh hello Agrippa this
looks lovely ah
oh I'm so strong did you see me just rip
that off the hinges Oh guy I am I'm so
amazingly strong it's unreal how strong
I am
hello this is a big circle I'm gonna go
get you go Nikki
oh that slime blocks the door but I am
NOT a bad person I mean not that bad you
will find something useful in the lower
cellar huh
this is gonna be a pretty jump scary one
isn't it
ah Marky no likey what's this what's all
this then what's this all about
what's all that what's that all about
don't trust you
this custom story is the cruel ways of
dr. Richard Jones yes okay that slime
blocks the door I need to get rid of
those slimes I'm out with a crowbar now
okay so obviously I need to find
something to get rid of the slime ah
here we go
hmm no dump here please
congratulations you came far but don't
trust anything down here I prepared some
traps for you thanks buddy thanks friend
ah oh you're the best dr. Jones you're
not the best dr. Jones you really aren't
the best you're less than the best
wait how did how did this happen wait a
minute damn it
well I mean what was the point of coming
down here this just loops back around so
I don't know oh how did this just get
here oh goody goody goody goody goody
goody do this all right what am I notes
still have any mementos nope no mementos
available oh man
Oh Illumina barrel flip oh no it was a
barrel roll yeah oh okay no didn't find
anything though
fam when this crowbar work yes he's got
a funny oh now I've just been going in a
circle so I'm gonna head back upstairs
Emily come on do you really have
important life things to do things that
are more important what the hell was
that
okay Lissy I don't know I just they did
give me a crowbar and expect me to do
whatever with it so I don't know I don't
know don't know what that's all about
don't know what's in here don't have
anything I think mm she does a monster
spawn behind me I'm pretty sure yes I'll
clever you are all watching me yes you
are
try to light your way with a clue also
was that something different than just
different kind of floor nothing special
nothing special okay mark behind me who
where Oh No huh not even a little bit
come on skulls gripa no gotta be away
check the paintings in all the rooms
that's a good idea but I think I did
didn't I yeah maybe I didn't maybe I
didn't probably worth it alright let's
see nothing in here
no painting see I already checked that
one just coat nothing there
painting in here nothing nothing nothing
nothing and the painting up here nothing
nothing nothing okay hello okay alright
nothing there anything in here get get
out of the way huh no nothing all right
whole lot of nothing whole lot of
nothing
whole lot of nothing anyone got any tips
on what I should do next
because I seem to be running around in
circle here to no avail
yeah whenever I get in the house like
this I just saw that F everything up
throw things around get out of here you
see ya nothing here I'm really curious
like why this was here use all the
tinderboxes that come on
use all the tinderboxes is that actually
a tip something about light your way so
I'm kind of inclined to believe you huh
Ken yeah and one more I'll come on one
more turn yeah no oh but how many
tinderbox do I had two more light all
the torches got it got it all the way
doing that right now lag about dip and
fluid OOP and that did nothing that did
nothing that did nothing at all
light all the things I don't have any
more tender boxes I don't have any more
tender boxes anymore
go to the wine room for a jar I don't
even know where that is where is that
where is light all of them well
congratulations I don't have anymore my
headphones broke did my headphones did
break and I have no more so I am
resorting to head earbuds hmm what's in
my inventory that that than that hmm yep
nothing
no I'm not gonna watch the season
premiere of Walking Dead because I don't
have cable I've said this before I'm
gonna go hunt around maybe I missed some
more tinderboxes back in the beginning
or something I have no idea if I really
am supposed to light all the things and
hmm I have no idea I am at a loss no no
no hello to all of France I'm the queen
of France nope
nothing nothing nothing nothing how long
have I been playing for about 17 minutes
pretty much 17 minutes on the dot toilet
paper oh wait right here
ah ah ha ha ha ha hey ha ha oh that
didn't do anything that didn't do
anything
ah bull honkey the unlocked door bull
honkey Oh
nope
gonna work I'm not working it's not
working mm-hmm ah hah hah hah hah hah
hah hah hah gimme gimme gimme gimme
gimme gimme
it gives ooh ooh ah ooh ah oh my kooky
who did that right then
okay it got a bellows up his butt what
kind of experiment was dr. Jones running
there oh okay don't die or you will end
up like these guys they all didn't pass
my test so be careful I will shove a
bellows up your butt and inflate you to
the size of a balloon
oh man so I'm guessing everyone's
telling me to use all my tinder boxes
were just trolling me how dare you how
dare you how dare you how dare you okay
I gotta get up there oh oh crap oh crap
oh come on
no no that's on what I wanted to do yeah
how flip Lao well oh no what's this see
how strong I was there did you see how
strong narrow okay smell how free strong
if you sent me something on Facebook and
you think you got ignored you are wrong
I get about I don't know 50 messages a
day I can't get to them all I literally
cannot so don't go on saying that you're
ignored and Facebook is a really bad
place to send me anything you should
send it through my email as opposed to
anything because Facebook is like the
worst messaging service in the world you
can't search names you can't search
anything yes I sense water monsters too
Oh finally I get to use this crowbar I
have that back please
can I can I have that back please no it
broke
okay nothing left to say run oh no boo
boo oh crap why did I come in here oh no
oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no what am i
doing what am i doing where am I going
oh my god what am i doing lot of acid
what is it - her slime away oh I get it
oh I see what I need
where is he where is he where is he
where 0 Z where Z where Z where Z where
Z where Z pretty crazy crazy crazy
where's the resumes amazing oh no no no
no no no no you gotta see him where is
he where is he buy me buy me buy me buy
me oh gosh open good go up please thank
you
new new new new new new no yes I did get
a new card who is why is he still here
why'd he go there okay I gotta use all
of my tactical ninja anti a media
monster skills and by that I mean a box
right um hey buddy hey buddy where you
at buddy maybe I should be a little more
sneaky just in case I can get away from
go over there good evening you didn't do
that don't move quickly and kitchen on
the way to the kitchen
yay oh my oh it was a little intense
oh nothing in there nothing in there
fine fine if that's the way you yeah all
right hmm life is anything dear a dog
head why do I need a dog's head anything
behind there
this guy seems to like to hide stuff aha
yeah yeah caboose Oh who's the best
who's the best there ever was I am hmm
that's me that's me oh this looks like a
trap
okay nothing nothing
storage let's see if all of you don't
know what the Queen of France references
from you need to see rejected this
animation it's on YouTube you can find
it's fantastic I'm the queen of France
neva alright I don't see anything back
here but yep Oh like a boss I am all
over these keys this guy cannot hide
from me cannot hide anything from me
oh I am so great chair come come come
huh yeah Oh buddy I throw that I just
had a chair and I threw my anus is
bleeding for the love of God and no that
is way ok prison key thank you I don't
know why oh I don't know why
oh I will say that this custom store is
a slightly different experience than
what I've been in previously
encountering selkie like vows founded
instantaneously cuz I am that great
come on scale anything up there nope
nope okay anything in here okay note I
heard about your plan I really hope you
will escape I saw you at that storage
picking up that hammer Jenna you are our
hope
but since yesterday I don't hear you
anymore is this tunnel done can we all
get out dear Louisa I found the letter
between two rocks down here they thought
they can escape but I disposed that
problem well now the cell isn't nice
small storeroom and I will keep it
locked okay sorry if I miss your
comments on the stream I'm a little
focused on what's going on here
okay
oh I'm betting there's gonna be a
jump-scare in one of these get me I am
too smart no loop okay I'm just being
sure to check under everything
absolutely everything just in case
there's like secrets or keys I know yeah
I got another key opens the key to this
special sell a bucket nope and nothing
in your bucket
let's see here yes blue I'm expecting
something to happen and the fact that
nothing's happening is kind of worrying
me
this hammer no well I mean it's a hammer
but hmm
behind there wait a minute the whole
thing is something ooh hey look it's
Agrippa again headless Agrippa oh I
don't like these things hmm
okay going down the lighted way is
probably a bad idea or something like
that
Hey look a hammer picked up a bloody
hammer okay don't jump-scare me don't
jump-scare me bro don't jump-scare me
bro ah this custom story is the cruel
ways of dr. Richard Jones okay
obvious I wasn't supposed to go this way
okay
dinner and markiplier oh yes
thunk thunk-thunk ax oh so strong just
the strongest hey buddy you don't look
so good yeah what I didn't even see
anything happen what happened
I'm so confused I'm I don't know if I
can get through that hole there I just
have a box or something let's see here
um well here's plenty of boxes they're
covering up the doorway and let me see
if I can get that dagger in there I'm
pretty sure I can one moment
uno momento here we go yeah boom boom
all right okay I live with this in again
so that I can get out yeah yeah give me
old blood-covered dagger those are my
favorite kind of old daggers dak daggers
daggers hello oil
these guys are sufficiently at
suspiciously absent of bellows of their
but I don't know what's going on I'm so
lost my life is changed forever
well I'll see here what is this then
what's all this what's with this door
huh
you know I always complain that there's
nothing under the stairs and finally
someone put something important under
the stairs so I'm very happy about that
get out of the way get out to the fair
you talk to Vivian oh there we go
now what's all this then oh do I get to
stab this guy Oh
Oh Emily you can brag all you want just
like I do
do I get to stab this guy what happened
he doesn't look dead he looks very much
alive I just got a key okay well okay I
didn't kill him
so I'm good I'm still Paragon I'm still
a good guy
towards Oh
yes I will upload this where the hell am
I going I don't even know it's it's for
one closed door in the mansion no I know
where that is I know where that is I
know where that is ah okay let me just
get out here I don't like being here I'm
getting out of here let's get out of
here get out of here out of here out of
here out here out out out of here out of
here out of here out here had a daddy
yeah for some reason my old head said
he's making crackling I don't know why
I've tried to fiddle with the settings
but I think it's just speakers are dying
so anyway we're here oh man ooh wait a
minute yeah up here okay
come on dr. Richard Jones it's time for
a final showdown
hmm loading huh no what the hell was he
doing there
crew that seriously what is he doing
there
would you love that whoo okey-dokey
hello hello okay okay he won't give me
why not
is that a trick that's a trick isn't it
it's a track your your narghay okay all
right then
okey-dokey
all right bin
should I be concerned
things don't seem to be quite right I'm
actually kind of confused as to what's
going on why is there a monster there
that can't get me why is that that way
that it is boys at another monster
oh that's Moo's man is a moose man that
looks like moose man I'm so confused
what are we doing what's going on look
amused hello ah give me the game gonna
kick your ass game Oh God how about that
okay
all right
okay so what do i what do i do I just
get out of here I think I didn't heed to
get out of you're right ah damnit watch
was the naked guys hmm okay I'm out of
here
oh no no no no you didn't hey buddy okay
I need to get around him and get that
key again I need to get I need to get
that key all right
get ready for some pro moves oh no box
why won't that box rug rugs gonna have
to do Pro moves Pro bro Pro bro Pro bro
bro bro bro come on oh yeah how'd you
like that rug but that hurt commander Oh
Ron Roget come on me bro come on come on
yeah yeah yeah hey
oh god I'm out of oil
oh god hey whoo hey that monsters gone
that's weird
oh man oh man okay
hello her boy all right was this the key
is in one of the prison sections but
well you will see I already saw dr.
Jones
I already saw and I beat the [ __ ] out of
it he was no match for the amazing thing
that is me I'll go to the garden I love
the garden sounds lovely
oops hello this doesn't look like any
garden that I know about this is you
were the first person who made it you
can go but please take this present
hahaha I did it I ran away
hahahahaha Oh God quote end tote oh man
I move
oh man oh man that was great that was a
really good one I I mean I really I
really really really liked that that was
really cool
huh I'm actually very very very
impressed
it was fun and I mean I like the
intricate puzzles we've had some of the
puzzles weren't as good as others but
yeah total experts I got away from that
they didn't expect my leet tree climbing
skills to come into play they didn't
know they didn't know man they didn't
know alright more amnesia custom stories
coming along the way just let me get out
of here
hoo boy Oh fun yeah we got more my next
one there's going to be
see kidnapped kidnapped is gonna be the
next one all right but anyway before I
start this next one I just want to say
that for anyone out there who's new my
name is obviously markiplier I ran the
YouTube channel markiplier game I doubt
there's many people new but thank you
all so much for joining me here we're
not done yet we got a lot to go but I
just wanted to take a moment to remind
everyone that the giveaway the giveaway
for the free t-shirt is still going on
if you want a free t-shirt it's very
very easy all you have to do all you
have to do is share one of my ration
compilations take a screenshot of it and
send it to that email address that I
just posted and get your name in the
raffle and I will get that all sent out
to you now all thank you for loading on
those and um we there's only been about
I think there's only been about 400
people that have entered so with 10
t-shirts given away there's still a
pretty good shot at you winning so
anyway thank you all so much Oh No thank
you Remnick Wisner yeah if you want to
donate to me there's a donation widget
down in the description below but thank
you all so much ah thank you all so much
for helping out yeah only 400 compared
to the 20000 subscribers that I have
that's not that much so I'm just saying
anyway thanks everybody for watching I'm
gonna I'm going to take a quick little
I'm gonna cut the stream real quick just
so I can separate the custom stories in
terms of videos that I have so I will I
will I will be right back